it's now arraigned here non-stop for
nine days
and more is expected eighteen
thousand people have already been
evacuated from their homes
that number is expected to treble with
heavy rain forecast to continue
for another four days
in sydney there's been up to 10 inches
of rainfall
we haven't seen this sort of deluge for
six decades
for residents leaning on each other is
key
we couldn't have done it without our
amazing friends and
neighbours and people coming together
and the resilience of our community is
strong so
the hawkesbury has that we've done this
before and
floods and fire and whatever else it
throws at us we've got this
all of this has been caused by an
extremely rare
weather event a low pressure cell is
sitting on land
running the length of the new south
wilds coast and it's colliding with a
high pressure cell
that's sitting south of us in the tasman
sea
that collision is causing all this
moisture to be continually drawn into
the sky
and dumped on us a little more than a
year ago
australia was battling some of the worst
bushfires
in our history scientists say climate
change is making extreme weather events
like
this more common
this time its rising water levels that
have isolated communities
rescue boats and helicopters are the
only route
to safety 38 disaster zones have been
declared in new south wales alone
where the rainfall is being described as
a one
in 100 year event
stay in there mate and it's not just
humans
needing to be rescued 10 million
australians are under some form of
weather warning
but everyone is being urged to stay
alert for the next
24 hours david richardson
sky news sydney australia